Susie is three times more likely to win
a race then marry how many times would
you expect married to win if they raise
36 times ok 36 races this is question 37
ok Susie is three times more likely to
win then Mary so Susie she right now
here's what we going to do put your pens
down for a second um this is phrase i
love I don't know who said I think a lot
of people different lot of different
people said because it's a good thing
which is that a problem well phrased is
half solved if you know how to look at
the question and phrase it properly it
just becomes super easy to solve ok so
let's think about it this way I want to
go back to when you were like purchasing
things and you were comparing different
amounts right so we've got is we've got
Susie when we've got married and in
terms of the races right Susie is three
times more likely than married to win a
race right so for every race Mary wins
Susie will win three races does that
make sense so simple scenario forget
about the 36 races for a second if we
just did four races four races okay if
every time Mary wins one Susie wins
three that's that's the four races
already right so Mary will win one right
and then Susie will win the other three
and that adds up to four does that make
sense ok now double it suppose we didn't
run four races suppose we ran eight now
clearly you can see Mary is going to win
twice as many races Mary will win twice
now how many races are they left there
will be the other six races that Susie
will win and you can see she is three
times more likely to win every time Mary
wins wants scissors three times
so therefore when you come to 36 races
right 36 races is 9 times as many races
as for a turd right so we went from here
to here by doubling here to here times
so do from 4s is up to 36 races that's
multiplying by 99 make sense so
therefore in this case there will not
win one shall win nine races right nine
races and Susie will not read three sure
we three times nine 27recent